first kevin mccarthy is calling it the
pelosi payoff
well i think we can say it's the pelosi
schumer payoff
democrats are now trying to ram what is
a massive
1.9 trillion with a t
dollar spending bill through the house
of representatives as early as tomorrow
now they want you
the american people to believe something
that's not true
they want you to believe this is an
emergency covert relief package that's
going to help we the people
nothing could be further from the truth
get this only nine percent
of the two trillion dollars goes towards
fighting
covet 19. nine percent nearly
700 billion dollars will not even be
spent
for years until after 2022.
as i checked this is 2021 and that
includes billions of dollars
in this bill that won't even be spent
until
2024. how is that in any way
uh categorized as emergency covert
relief then to make matters worse
the bulk of the spending bill has
nothing at all whatsoever
to do with getting money directly into
the hands
of the american people those who
desperately need it
but per usual joe biden seems totally
unaware
and totally clueless take a look we need
congress to pass my american rescue plan
that deals with the immediate crisis the
urgency
now critics say my plan is too big
that it costs 1.9 trillion dollars so
that's too much
let me ask them what would they have me
cut
what would that be leave out
okay i'll answer i'll tell you what to
cut joe we'll start with the 350
billion dollar bailouts for
irresponsible state and local
governments
in other words this money would go
towards blue
high-tax states blue states with massive
budget deficits
states that tax their residents into
oblivion
states that never balance their budgets
and are now looking
for a handout from voters in red states
who elect politicians governors that are
fiscally responsible
state legislatures that don't raise
taxes
states that actually balance their
budget and fully fund pensions
and didn't buy into the insane draconian
shutdowns like new york and new jersey
in california and michigan
in other words the democrats want to
redistribute money
from states like texas and florida that
are fiscally responsible
and give it to governors like newsom
cuomo whitmer murphy and wolf
that are not fiscally responsible now
i'd also cut
joe if you're asking the 112 million
dollar tunnel
in silicon valley i think they have
enough of their own money
this is just outside of nancy pelosi's
district
tell me joe how's that coveted relief
and i have more areas joe for you to cut
the 1.5 billion dollars at an earmark
for the
seaway international bridge which
connects
canada to new york in chuck schumer's
home state of new york
you can cut that money for emergency
covert relief out also
you can also cut the 40 billion dollars
for colleges and universities
that have been collecting tuition the
entire time
and you can also cut the 750 million for
quote global health
in other words health care for people in
other countries uh
we can barely afford health care for
everyone here and the
illegal immigrants you want to give
health care to and joe
while you're at it you can also cut the
500 million dollars for museums and
libraries
and the arts and humanities and i failed
to see how one billion dollars for quote
an equity
commission and other assistance to
advance racial justice
in farming has anything at all
whatsoever to do with
culver 19 emergency release relief
this is a wish list for the radical left
that's all this
is this is a pelosi schumer payoff
and a payoff to blue states and radicals
in the democratic party
and now tonight even some democrats
finally
getting to the bottom of the bill are
yeah beginning to get uncomfortable with
the bill because they're going to have
to answer for this in less than two
years
any bill that has uh 1.9
trillion dollars there will be one line
that will probably be
somewhat embarrassing right poppy but i
tell you what this is
it's embarrassing and that's a hundred
and one and a half million dollars
of taxpayer money and i'm just saying
are you comfortable with it
yes yes or no i'm not comfortable i'm
never comfortable with it
now let's not forget here it's not just
the pork and the payouts democrats
were also trying to use the bill as a
trojan horse
for their 15 minimum wage which
according to the cbo
that would cost 1.4 million jobs
oh in the middle of a pandemic not a
good idea
in the middle of eliminating high paying
career six figure paying jobs
career jobs in the energy sector not a
good idea
a job where the job market's going to be
flooded with
11 to 15 million illegal immigrants
uh not a good idea but also breaking
tonight
the u.s parliamentary parliamentarian by
the way ruled that the minimum wage
increase
must be stripped from the bill there is
some hope